in the Danish capital Copenhagen
everything is easily reached by bike the
listed building that makalah visa neck
calls home is located in a quiet street
in the city centre
hello welcome to my home
the fashion designer shares the 190
square meter five room apartment with
her son it boasts original stuccoed
ceilings original doors and window
frames just as they were 100 years ago
when the house was built I was not
allowed to change anything else but to
repaint the walls and to pigment to the
floors that's a part of living in an
historical apartment where you actually
feel that there has been a history
before you came I love it I could never
imagine to live in a new house even the
cupboards and tiles in the kitchen are
original features
these are from the when the house was
built in 1915 and they are very
historical preserved for me they're
lovely because I really like everything
goes with ornaments and once they really
inspired me for a piece of clothes for
prints on clothes and I think they are
gorgeous these necks own fashions
reflect the focus on inspiring details
and creative mix of materials that
define her interior style she works from
home after 20 years with big-name houses
like Christian Lacroix she now has her
own label it's very important to me to
be in a personal environment
I can always don't have an idea here on
my table I can turn around and find a
wonderful new sill adult green color for
the new collection I'm always on an
inspiration trip it could be Sunday
night at 8 o'clock I have an idea so for
me there is a very there's no fine line
between work and private line Makara
spends a lot of time traveling both for
business and pleasure souvenirs from her
travels can be found in her apartment
this is a special piece because I found
her in the flea market in New York and
of course we all my son and me was not
clear about how we should take her home
because she was quite heavy so she
traveled on in the hand luggage with us
so she was sitting next to us in the
airplane
this piece also has a special story
because it was in Hanoi in Vietnam I was
going by a little shop with a tailor and
we had a very traditional little tailor
Vietnamese jacket with the traditional
clothing and it was quilted and I really
loved it and then I asked him to do a
big blanket in the same fabric and the
same quilt nice neck cleverly combines
different styles and periods
the Danish modern classic pieces
especially like these couches and a lot
of other pieces is very well blending in
with the Asian Japanese furniture design
because it's a story about they actually
speak very well together it's less is
more there's nothing extra McCallum ease
necks apartment reflects her personal
aesthetic it's a serene sophisticated
space with personal memories from around
the world
you